so the tricks we're going to talk about  today can be used not only in social  but pretty much um everywhere i call  them  kately's social writing rules so my team  calls me kately  i'm kately from lately they all have to  use these rules  um they shame each other  when they forget to um so it becomes  addictive pretty quickly  um in fact my customer service head  lauren said that she recently  out wrote another customer service  person from a company and got a thousand  dollars  in credit for a return that they  originally didn't want to give her by  using these rules these rules are the  same rules that are the bedrock for  lately's ai  that we discussed earlier they're also  the same rules that get  us a 98 sales conversion  98 um and that's with no paid ads no  cold calls and no cold emails this is  what we do for ourselves  these are also the same rules that got  us from 24 000 mrr to 95 000 mrr in 12  months so it's all about  how to use writing to scale your startup